[Música]
Ucrania conmemora el primer año de la
Guerra sin miras a un acuerdo de paz el
presidente
encabeza actos simbólicos repasamos 765
días de un conflicto que sorprendió al
mundo
en Estados Unidos mientras el norte
soporta una tormenta invernal con
temperaturas bajo cero e interrupciones
en los servicios en la costa este se
esperan temperaturas inusualmente altas
y Harvey weinstein recibió una condenada
por violencia machista el ex Afamado
productor de Hollywood tiene una nueva
pena de 16 años de prisión o por la
violación de una actriz en Los Ángeles
en 2013
Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y aquí están
las noticias de France 24 comenzamos en
Ucrania que conmemora un año desde la
invasión rusa a su país el 24 de febrero
de 2022 en un discurso televisado el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin anunciaba
lo que él llamó una operación militar
especial para desgasificar Ucrania
columnas de tanques cruzaron la frontera
occidente reaccionó rápidamente con
sanciones a Moscú y ayuda militar para
el gobierno de zelenski
el 24 de febrero los temores del mundo
se hicieron realidad
[Música]
decidí llevar a cabo una operación
militar especial cuyo objetivo es
proteger a las personas que han sido
intimidadas y sometidas al genocidio por
el régimen de kiev durante 8 años
[Música]
se reportaron ataques en todo el
territorio y los civiles colapsaron las
vías tratando de huir de la capital
[Música]
ya estamos entregando armas y las
entregaremos para defender nuestro país
a todos los que quieran y tengan la
capacidad de defender nuestra soberanía
estas imágenes de filas kilométricas de
tanques rusos A las afueras de kiev
hicieron pensar que la capital caería
pronto sin embargo el esfuerzo de Moscú
duró poco la fuerte resistencia
ucraniana en el norte del país sumada a
las informaciones de inteligencia
estadounidense asestaron un duro golpe a
la primera fase de la operación de Putin
millones de ucranianos huyen de su país
las fronteras de Polonia y Rumanía se
abarrotan se les quita la orden de
evitar la salida a los hombres de entre
18 y 60 años
la batalla se concentra enseguida en la
ciudad de maripol famosa por ser el
hogar del controvertido regimiento a
soft de ideología ultranacionalista que
se atrinchera en la planta metalúrgica
de asofal El bombardeo ruso a un
hospital materno infantil y genera una
Nueva Ola de rechazo internacional
[Música]
el 21 de mayo con la ciudad de reducida
a cenizas los últimos resistentes del
Batallón se rinden
los días 2 y 3 de abril los ucranianos
descubren decenas de cadáveres de
civiles esparcidos por la calle o
enterrados en fosas en la localidad de
bucha A las afueras
Moscú rechaza las acusaciones de
crímenes de guerra y dice que las
imágenes de los cuerpos son falsas
con el despliegue de las tropas rusas
hacia el don vass quien comienza a vivir
una relativa seguridad y los líderes
mundiales se animan a visitar la capital
ucraniana para mostrar su apoyo
La balanza de la guerra se inclina a
favor de Moscú en el don Baz el 25 de
junio la ciudad de ucraniana de
severodoniese cae bajo ocupación rusa el
3 de Julio
Moscú toma el control de la última
ciudad de la región del lugars que aún
estaba bajo control ucraniano el 29 de
agosto con un conflicto estancado
Ucrania denuncia una contraofensiva en
la región de gersón en el sur del país
los rusos se movilizan dejando
descubierto el frente Norte y en
septiembre quién sorprende a las
defensas rusas en el noreste del país
lanzando una contraofensiva en la región
de jarquín
en respuesta el 21 de septiembre de
Rusia anuncia una movilización parcial
de sus ciudadanos
los daños en la logística debilitan a
las tropas rusas en el sur y A mediados
de octubre las autoridades rusas ordenan
abandonar gersón
el 9 de noviembre las fuerzas de Ucrania
entran victoriosas la única gran ciudad
que los rusos habían logrado capturar
el 15 de noviembre el mundo contiene la
respiración un misil cae en territorio
de Polonia país miembro de la otan sin
embargo tras una serie de
investigaciones Estados Unidos señala
que se trata de un misil antiaéreo s-300
disparado por Ucrania y que cayó en la
frontera por error
[Música]
el 21 de diciembre esqui sale por
primera vez desde Ucrania desde el
inicio de la invasión viaja a Washington
en los últimos días de enero occidente
dobla su Apuesta por Ucrania y decide
enviar tanques Reino Unido anuncia a sus
Challenger 2 tras unas intensas
presiones de sus aliados Alemania cede Y
promete los leopardos Estados Unidos los
M1 abrams
Mientras tanto los combates rugen en el
este Rusia reclama tibios avances en el
don Baz capturando la localidad de
soledad y rodeando la ciudad de bacmut
en Estados Unidos las tormentas
invernales provocan ventiscas y
temperaturas bajo cero en gran parte del
país hay retrasos y cancelaciones de
vuelos y en cinco estados más de 800.000
casas sin electricidad Mientras tanto se
esperan temperaturas inusualmente altas
en la costa este
las máquinas quitanieves están luchando
para despejar las carreteras y
autopistas desde Arizona hasta Wyoming
en Dakota del Sur El jefe del
Departamento de Obras Públicas de Six
Falls ha declarado que sus equipos
trabajan sin descanso para hacer frente
a la tormenta invernal
nuestros operadores de barrido han
estado fuera desde ayer están de vuelta
en sus turnos de 12 horas Así que vamos
a correr turnos de 24 horas hasta que lo
logremos Es probable que trabajen hasta
el domingo y potencialmente hasta la
próxima semana en estos turnos de 12
horas las condiciones en las carreteras
interestatales del país son malas con
vías heladas y con visibilidad casi nula
esta cámara capta el momento en que un
tractor remolque pierde el control y
derrapa en Wyoming funcionarios de todo
el medio oeste instaron a la gente a
permanecer fuera de las carreteras
consejo acogido por algunos camioneros
en Wisconsin mientras cenábamos las
carreteras empeoraban y empeoraban y
empeoraban y comentamos sabes que no
merece la pena así que dijimos vamos a
quedarnos Aquí esta noche y estará salvo
la enorme tormenta ha provocado el
cierre de escuelas y la interrupción de
los viajes causando cientos de
cancelaciones y retrasos de vuelos y ha
dejado sin electricidad a más de 800.000
casas y empresas en cinco estados el
tiempo salvaje incluso ha traído
chubascos a las zonas desérticas fuera
de Los Ángeles algo que está encantando
a los residentes
hace un frío muy fuerte No estoy
acostumbrada a ver nieve en el desierto
pero es emocionante el hecho de que esté
nevando estoy muy muy emocionada soy
como una niña de 33 años estoy súper
emocionada Mientras tanto Al otro lado
del país se preparan para temperaturas
inusualmente altas a lo largo de la
costa este Se podrían alcanzar hasta 40
grados por encima de lo normal se espera
que en Washington DC se alcancen los 26
grados centígrados una máxima no vista
desde 1874
recibió una nueva sentencia por
violencia machista un tribunal de Los
Ángeles ordenó 16 años de prisión por
violación y abuso sexual el ex productor
de Hollywood y ya se encontraba pagando
una condena de 23 años de Nueva York que
por delitos similares que se destaparon
con el movimiento mito y en Guatemala se
cumplió un año de prisión de la fiscal
anticorrupción Virginia a la Parra
condenada a cuatro años por
presuntamente haber filtrado de
información reservada amnistía
internacional la declaró presa de
conciencia nos cuenta nuestro
corresponsal Andrés Suárez
Virginia la Parra condensa para
organismos de derechos humanos y
colectivos feministas el rostro de quien
padece la injusticia y la
criminalización que se da en Guatemala
en contra de sus jueces y Fiscales que
luchan por abolir la corrupción la ex
fiscal anticorrupción la Parra fue
arrestada hace exactamente un año en la
ciudad de Quetzaltenango luego de haber
investigado y denunciado a un otro
fiscal que habría revelado información
de un caso que se encontraba bajo
reserva el juicio contra la Parra se fue
extendiendo al punto de ligarla a un
otro proceso judicial de negarle a su
defensa por seis veces la solicitud de
arresto domiciliario y de Finalmente
condenarla a cuatro años de prisión para
amnistía internacional se trata de una
completa injusticia la declaró como
presa de conciencia y exige el estado de
Guatemala su Liberación inmediata más
cuando su salud se encuentra en un grave
estado de deterioro la Parra no pudo
salir del país como otros 30 jueces y
fiscales que viéndose amenazados por una
denominada persecución judicial del
gobierno se encuentran en el exilio la
mayoría de ellos por haber juzgado y o
investigado a funcionarios relacionados
en actos de corrupción que involucran
incluso al presidente Alejandro yamatei
esto es France 24
[Música]